sus órganos pélvicos se mantienen en su
lugar gracias a los músculos y tejidos
de su pelvis
si estos músculos y tejidos se debilitan
o se desgarran sus órganos pélvicos
pueden caer dentro de su vagina
produciendo un prolapso si su vejiga o
su letra caen sobre la pared vaginal
frontal usted tiene visto retrocede su
médico puede recomendar una cop o rafia
anterior durante la cual el cirujano
hará una incisión en su vagina empujar a
los órganos devolviendo los a su lugar y
suturar a el tejido para mantener la
vejiga en su lugar si su recto protege
hacia la pared vaginal posterior usted
tiene rectos l es posible que necesite
una col porra fia posterior durante la
cual su cirujano hará una incisión en su
vagina empujará el recto hacia arriba y
suturar a el tejido para apoyar el área
la suspensión de la cúpula vaginal
repara el prolapso del revestimiento
pélvico y del intestino delgado ocurrido
en la parte superior de la vagina
denominado entero se le mediante una
incisión vaginal su cirujano empujará el
intestino delgado colocándolo en su
posición original y unirá la parte
superior de la vagina a ligamentos
fuertes de la pelvis si tiene un
prolapso uterino su cirujano puede
repararlo utilizando instrumentos
laparoscópicos su cirujano insertará una
cámara con linterna dentro de su abdomen
bajo para ver sus órganos pélvicos en
una pantalla de vídeo utilizando
herramientas especiales su cirujano
levantará y apoyará su útero
suspendiéndolo desde ligamentos de la
base de su columna